hey what it do is pow wow baby boy
terminology hey check us out on the
bootleg cave podcast baby what it do
all right man boo lay cap show special
guests in here my guys paul wall
terminology
you guys have come together for a
project what is the name of the album
start to finish oh by the way it's right
here yeah yeah by the way i love the
artwork start to finish now paul you've
obviously um
you're no stranger neither of you are
strangers to collab projects right 1982
is a brand that's crazy you've done
joint albums you kind of came into the
game with a millionaire doing color
color changing click um
what uh what made this just
such an easy thing to happen man
static yeah for sure yeah
both of us were just you know dope mcs
of course you know so it's something
that maybe might be abstract us coming
together in some people's minds because
our styles are so different right but
the the core elements of our styles are
similar we're dope we care about the
craft we care about the art of it you
know we care about how it sounds not
we're not trying to do nothing gimmicky
or nothing like that we're trying to be
true to who we are true to hip-hop true
to whatever we represent uh and that's
the same thing with both of us so it was
an easy natural fit me and static you
know we we kind of kicked it off when we
did a project together called give
thanks
and we did a song on there and after
that song you know we we really just
messed good we vibe real good we got to
be great friends you know what i'm
saying and then next thing you know we
did a song with pete rock and then from
there it's like you know what maybe you
just do a little project together
and it's done yeah it's crazy paul cause
like i feel like people who might be
just like surface level fans of what you
do
and haven't really been paying attention
to what you've been up to the last like
ten years would be like yo paul walver
pete rockstar static selector like man i
talk to him about that all the time and
i thank him and static for that
opportunity because normally if like you
said just the
casual powerwall fans there's a box that
i'm in yes and if i do anything outside
of that box it's like what is he doing
they don't you know you don't get a
chance to do it
but to be able to spin on static select
the beats or p rock beats or terminology
beat man it was you know definitely it
brought something out of me that i fell
in love with you know like i said with
the gift thanks it was like
man this is the greatest thing i ever
did in terms of hip-hop in my mind and a
lot of people mind people who hear it
because a lot of people haven't heard it
it's kind of under the radar but uh you
know the people who have heard it they
like man where is this man we need some
more of this so of course you know
during the
start to finish this is like a part two
for me to get things yeah yeah to be
able to to to express myself
on these type of beats in a different
way because it brings something out of
you different than if i'm wrapping on
you know one of my texas type of beat so
it just brings something out of me that
oh i think about time man thanks for
this opportunity to showcase this type
of talent to an audience that would be
open to it you know yeah some people
they might not want to hear they might
want to hear only me talking about
grills or me right right right you know
doing like i say some slab music or
something do you get the free grill off
the rib because you got the album
we go
get my grill fitted last time i went to
houston to shoot the videos and we were
just running and gunning like we did
three videos four videos and like 48
hours so you know i can get to and get
my [ __ ] yeah but i'm definitely going to
get them how is the grill business
because i feel like it's made
there was like a small little time where
it kind of died out but it's back man
this is uh you know it's as a
businessman in any type of business
there's always going to be cycles of
course things are going to come and go
you got to adjust to the cycle you got
to adjust to the consumer you got to try
to find a way to you know reconnect with
the consumers and you know the cultures
would dictate the grills you know so we
can sit there and sell them all day we
can do whatever we come we come up with
all the new styles all day but if the
culture don't want it then it is dead so
it was a time when you know it's like
grills came from being an underground
thing to being mainstream to being
everybody's got grills and it's no
longer something cultural is now a
everyday mainstream fad or a trend with
all fairs and trends they come and go so
when it became the national trend you
know it's like the underground and the
culture the streets was like man [ __ ]
this
once nelly dropped grills did it was
like
well it's kind of like that that brought
the peak and then it took it to the next
level and then it was like oh my god
where are we going
but then they came back when the youth
came with them yeah the new generation
was like man i want some grills and they
come in and get grills they brought it
back to where now i feel like
it's a a mainstay of jewelry where
change definitely you need the grill
earring grill help me with the hygiene
perspective of grills because a lot of
grown-ass men i know have metal in their
mouth yes have the worst [ __ ] breath
on the planet this is this is a known
thing yeah i'm like bro get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] backwood grill
breath bruh
how do you prevent the breath from
smelling like [ __ ] if you have a grill
proper hygiene whatever normal hygiene
is recommended which is brushing your
teeth two times a day two to three times
a day but who brush their teeth three
times a day two times a day and clean
your grills out you know some people eat
with them or they smoke with them or
they drink coffee or whatever with them
well think about it you you're doing
that and you're not cleaning them and
stuff staying in there it's creating
bacteria it's gonna stink and your
breath is gonna stink and a lot of
people they'll put on the grills and to
them it's a oh i don't need to brush my
teeth because i got grills it's it's a
mental thing it's a mental thing where
you feel like you don't have to but it's
also to me you just gotta get on the
schedule no matter what i brush my teeth
in the morning when i wake up whether i
feel like a stink well i don't know
whether i ate something that morning or
eight something the night before or
anything normal human [ __ ] right i
always brush your teeth in the morning i
always brush your teeth at night but
them stink grills man they something see
but let me tell you man let me tell you
this cory blunt shout out to corey blunt
og triple og slab originator man okay
he had permanent goatee
he went to the feds for 30 years
came out got new gold teeth so he got
the old ones removed his teeth
underneath pearly white nothing wrong
with them so
you can have permanent grills for 30
plus years
and nothing go wrong with your teeth now
most people who get permanent grills
they not flossing or brushing their
teeth every day so of course if you
don't floss you don't brush your teeth
you don't take care of yourself it's
going to get rotten and you can see the
horror stories of people with permanent
gold teeth they take them out man it
ain't what's up it's not good and this
is just normal grown-up [ __ ] that's
regular [ __ ] though you're supposed to
brush your teeth everyday right right
wash your face
right before we bring them to school you
brush your teeth
like come on that's the first thing you
learn have you ever had someone uh like
you know we hear about people who get
like a they'll go to like ran a tire and
rent their wheels is there is there a
grill bill a arena grill yeah can
someone can someone get a note on a
grill from you uh we definitely do
payment plans and things like that but
uh in terms of renting the grills you
know they're all custom-made no they're
not renting i just mean in terms of like
if i want to come in and like i got i
only got 10 percent can i get oh yeah
like buy it on layaway kind of yeah for
sure we now we don't make payments like
uh we'll take it in and you can pay us
later but we'll take like a layaway plan
and then when you get to a certain point
okay bet now you can take degrees you
pull them off to the side and say hey
buddy uh
priorities yeah
it's tough sometimes when you see people
who they hit their first lick or they're
just coming up they just made some money
and now they want to blow it all on some
jury i definitely there's been some
times where i'm like look
listen you're a businessman different
jury yeah yeah but
but just the uh the human in me is like
man i'm gonna see this person in a
couple years and they're gonna you know
i'm in my mind they're gonna feel a
certain way but they blew all their
money on jury and they lost it all they
have nothing so far but the fact is a
lot of those people don't care when they
blow it all on jury and i see them five
years later and they they're they're
like proud yeah man remember when i came
here and blew 50 grand you're right man
it's a mentality thing you're proud of
that like that ain't that man where the
jury at i don't know where it's at i
lost it anyway i'm gonna go put some gas
in my ultima yeah
[Music]
did you i saw um
that uh bun put together the uh houston
rodeo thing were you part of that yeah
man thank you thank you bun b for
putting that man that was some serious
now the houston rodeo for me just came
on i know it's the biggest rodeo right
but me and my wife been watching
yellowstone have y'all seen that [ __ ]
yeah yeah that [ __ ] is gasping man
[ __ ] yeah kevin costner bro man oh no
ranch man put me up in that bunk house
anyway so i was like my wife said she
want me to dress like rip you need to
dress like real
that's funny but i was like being my
wife and i was like yeah we should go to
the rodeo i want to go you know like
let's just go yeah let's just go [ __ ]
it's a crazy atmosphere and it's
explaining it to somebody who's not like
from texas or from houston or who's a
part of that then it's like it's trying
to you know it's like foreign but in
okay it's a rodeo livestock showrodeo in
houston where they actually do livestock
contests you know this cow won this
prize this whatever one then there's
actual rodeo where there's cowboys out
there you know uh last on
some you know bulls or whatever they got
the whatever rodeo stuff they got where
you on the horse or yeah they bucking
you off all of that type they got a
little kid one where they got kids
riding on sheep trying to hang on you
know it's some texas [ __ ] for real it
definitely it definitely is and then
there's the uh the fair part of it with
all the food you know the the because
it's that it's not like the stadium
right yeah it's where the where the
texans play yes oh yeah sure that's the
people it's huge the parking lot's huge
so it's uh definitely it's like a couple
weeks long and they you know usually it
is mostly country artists
but they will have some tejano artists
uh you know selena was when she did the
rodeo that's like one of the most
historic concerts ever like just it's
like when she did the rodeo that's like
the original woodstock wow concert like
the type of history that goes with it um
and then you know cardi b they
traditionally don't have hip-hop dad
cardi b do it cardi b did it and i think
chance the rapper did it um and i think
those are the only rappers bum b came
out as a special guest for leon bridges
and i think maybe for beyonce when
beyonce was there but in terms of
rappers headline and it was only carded
b and chance the rapper so for houston
hip-hop
who all did button have a part of the
show
he um had a it was like a medley of
artists you know he had lele shout out
to lele um she's on i think disney
nickelodeon she's also a rapper from
houston uh
uh then he had uh h-town somebody
rocking you know boots yeah latoya lucky
um myself slim thug zero
devin the dude uh ronnie spencer um
willie d came out
esg lil kiki chamillionaire came out
toby in the wig way uh toby so fire yeah
yeah well i watched it on youtube
because i was there like a couple weeks
before you know you said with paul and
and bunny bo was telling me like yo term
this is the biggest [ __ ] i've ever done
in my life it's a big deal man he's like
you don't understand like 90 000 people
and this is our hood so he's explaining
you know i had never even heard of that
[ __ ] so he's explaining it to me so
after they did it i'm like yo let me go
on youtube and watch it it's like an
hour long the medley so i watched it and
one of my favorite thing was not only
did he put on every single artist from
his hood like every artist ever he
didn't miss nobody he brought out like
everybody that he kept changing his fits
the fitz was so fly he got the cowboy
[ __ ] then like j prince come out with
the with the cowboy [ __ ] it was just so
like ill like he kept going in the back
come out with a different fur coat like
all this different flaw [ __ ] that was
that's what i thought was fly like put
on your peoples and
the only person who could really
probably pull that off was bun yeah yeah
man for sure man and like i was saying
about the selena thing when she
performed she had this iconic dress that
she wore it was like a purple dress you
know you know when jayla wore that green
dress to the grammy's everybody i know i
know that that's what the celebrities
look the same way so that's how you know
so many people that you know came to
perform it was just you know they they i
don't think they grasped the magnitude
until they were there kind of yeah
because but definitely the people who
were into it were like man we should
bond for show man jake prince you know
you want to wear something that's going
to be iconic that people are going to
remember for years man that says you
know he suddenly swore that at the rodeo
you know what record did you do i did uh
still tipping uh with slim thug and then
i did uh sitting sideways with big pokey
big pocket was there also a little i'm
remembering all the people that little
flip was there yeah
little flip was there shot the flip did
a couple records yeah i think it was
yeah but you know once again with the
clothes i think bun changed about four
times yeah yeah like watch that on
youtube when you get a minute
the fits he had was crazy he went from
like urban hip-hop to straight cowboy
[ __ ] to like yo it was crazy man check
the fits the fitz is it's crazy yo we
got to stop the interview real quick
tell us about uh i'm gonna tell you
about our partners in my bookie man make
sure you go to mybookie.ag right now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now
just go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're gonna give
you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand a bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because jokic is going to [ __ ]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one
anyway my bookie.ag my bookie just
[ __ ] googled the [ __ ] my bookie use
the promo code bootleg and they will
match your deposit free money free money
up to a thousand dollars let's get back
to the interview yo it's crazy because
like um
and when i was in high school and you
guys
kind of had that the first houston run
i want to say that was like oh 405
oh three
four five yeah yeah even though three
yeah and uh
it felt very
i remember there was like the double xl
cover or the source cover don't mess
with texas everybody was on the cover
slim thug signed the star trek like uh
you you were doing your thing i mean
switcher house was a movement
um
there are so many artists now from
houston like when we think of travis
scott like travis scott's one of the
biggest artists in the world right and
he obviously bangs houston heavy astro
world all that right but like i feel
like
i don't know if it feels like there's
like a unison movement out of the city
with the newer artists do you feel
because back then it felt like there was
a real movement the cohesiveness yeah
well um yeah i don't think it is
necessarily is now when we came out
the movement was a little different
because there was the screwed up click
artist and the switch house artist and
it was a similar style of rap where you
know we had similar subject matter
similar type of slow down type of beats
of course you know switch house we got
the style from screw but being that
there was the screwed up all the artists
that were around at the time at our time
you know the switch house and squirtle
click artist
we had us you know the movement was
there because we had a similar style we
had a similar fan base all of that
whereas now you got lizzo
uh normani mm-hmm megan the stallion
maxo cream toby new wigway sauce walker
travis scott don toliver
where everyone's got their own vibe dont
over chat with me
from houston yeah dr oliver travis scott
got similar style but it's way different
than toby
and that's completely different than
sauce walker and that's so different
than normani or lizzo you know so it's
you know it's it's
not to mention all of the other houston
artists that are like blowing up right
now on tick-tock or the non-traditional
methods that we came up that i don't
even know about yet but they popping and
you know getting 50 000 a show and i
don't even know them you know those
artists out there too where they
building their fan bases up
you know outside of the houston
you know market uh and i think that's a
little bit wide too where you know when
we came we
rep texas to the fullest well they also
do but when people played our music they
played it as a pride thing too they're
repping texas by playing on music
and you guys had a very unison
like sonic movement i feel like yeah
where it'd be like even if you listen to
like already platinum from slim thug
like right right even with pharrell
production you'd be like nah this is
some texas [ __ ] yeah exactly exactly but
they're all the artists there they still
rep h-town like you said for sure
they're not kind of known as being
h-town where when you think of us you
think oh h-town texas you know 100 um
what is there any plan to get you and uh
millionaire [ __ ] up on the dsps anywhere
i'll be trying to talk man he's making
too much money he got to go broke before
we do something i'm like bro i gotta get
too much i'm gonna keep pulling up all
these shitty quality links on youtube
and that piff when i seen them on at the
rodeo that's the first thing i said all
right well we can we gonna get get your
mind correct part two i told him man we
need to drop some as the nft man we
could drop it as a pre-sale where we
ain't dropping it till we pre-sale a
hundred thousand bro i'm telling you you
got too
[ __ ] was like to me like
i used to sell a lot of mixtapes to swap
me
during that era and uh
that was kind of to me like the very
underrated like when i that's my
favorite [ __ ] from y'all yeah to go back
and listen to yeah i'll be trying though
i've been trying that's man
yo it's so crazy too because even like
you said like the screwed up [ __ ] was so
wild in that time like i would have
everyone hit me
all my homies
from az would be like yo
could you screw and drop the 50 cent
album for me yeah yeah
or like everybody like really there was
like a like in phoenix you know
everybody wanted every album to be
chopped and screwed yeah and my cousin
was one of those guys i didn't [ __ ] i
was like bro i don't i mean yeah yeah
like i don't get it maybe i'm not on
lean i don't know what it is yeah but no
it's it's crazy but it's good to see you
guys uh coming together in in 2022 man
term of course you're always active yeah
yeah of course um i feel like you're
always dropping um
how many albums are you in so far i got
44 projects hello
what do you got 20 i don't know [ __ ]
i'll get it i
you know uh maybe he just didn't count
him you know what i'm saying but uh but
yeah we yeah man we rap that's what we
do i mean you got to be north at 20 at
least with all the joint projects
because you know a lot of them don't
come up on the dsps you know what i mean
so i'm counting all of them like from
not like demos i'm kind of like the real
ones with the barcodes and actually 44
44 yeah wow it's about five done too
just sitting there so that are coming
soon yeah because you know one at a time
you know what i'm saying
that's got to be some nice just residual
catalog income coming in it's pretty
cool i i have a joke with my daughter
right she used to wake up and go to
school in the morning and she'd be mad
as hell at me she'd be like
why do you get to sleep all day like
she'd be mad because she waking up at
six
teeth
looking at me in the bed like bye so i
had to sit her down one day i'm like i
make money when i sleep
every day yeah i don't have to go to
work i don't have to go to school i
already put in my work
so what you got to do is figure out how
you're going to do a bunch of things
that'll make you money while you're
sleeping and like once i i broke that
down to her
she she you know she's only 10. she
already gets it it's like i get it dad
i'm gonna write books i'ma sell art i'm
gonna make jewelry so that way people
can go on my website and buy it while
i'm at school and i'm making money and
i'm like exactly
you know that's that's what it is you
know i i feel like if you're an
independent artist and you're not always
dropping you're slipping because it's
like
like you said you're just adding to like
it's free money you're i mean yeah and
it's and the overhead of making music
nowadays is not what it used to be right
like you used to have to go to the
studio and have it like now it's like if
you really
you could record at your house yeah in
fact you should do it on your iphone if
you if you know how to really want to
you know you really know how i mean to
make that album would it cost us you
know 10 times more
10 years ago 20 years ago so basically
everybody on there is our friend yeah i
know i'm seeing uh of course bun is on
the album shout out to ysp shot crooked
eyes on there yup
nems
gorilla names
been around a long time finally getting
his shine
that's what we love though we you know
being paul we kind of like some we
underdogs like you know saying people
know my name all through the industry i
got a lot of die-hard fans uh obviously
paul's had commercial success but
still we you know we still feel like we
still want people to hear what we got to
say so
it's still kind of like an underdog
how do you feel about because your area
is finally i feel like there's some
bias nationally right and she's been
doing her thing for a very long time but
it was good to see her finally break
through exactly uh
millie's is going crazy killing it uh
there's always i just feel like boston's
always kind of been a
uh
underappreciated or maybe just there
hasn't been a
big of enough i mean it's really been
you and static really static and slain
for a long time yeah you know i mean uh
the first generation was like edo g
uh you know almighty rso
um you know big sugan guru started
gangstar of course so you know the 80s
to the early 90s
you know being that boston is so close
to new york
it there is a golden era of boston
hip-hop and then that next wave was like
you know esoteric who does our face now
mr lift the underground yeah that mr
left was crazy right then that next
that's the dev joke right uh chrome
snatcher yeah that scientific resting
piece from lawrence so like that was the
original 80s and 90s wave and then me
static slain rex we came after and we
held it down for like 10 whole years it
was just us like it wasn't it wasn't
nothing for sure for sure then now this
era we got like bia millie's uh what's
his name uh joining lucas cousins stays
this how far is jordan from boston he
like 45 minutes you know he's trying to
join her lucas he's going crazy he's
fired too so it's just like now it's
starting to get you know the artist is
starting to get national recognition
which feels good for the city because
for a long time like i said it was just
me and static and slain you know is it
hard to get over the um stereotype of
being from boston because i feel like
when people think of boston they think
of racist white people they do but you
know like you said i'm from lawrence
which is way different everybody's
puerto rican and dominican and lawrence
lots of beautiful women in lawrence yeah
you know the vibe so it's like in my
city it's it's more like the bronx it's
right little bronx so that's that's kind
of been my mission was to put the 978
put lawrence on the map since i came in
the game when i had the k-swiss deal i
was in all the double xls for nine
months k swiss all this lawrence max
lawrence mass you know uh double xl sean
proved lawrence mass source unsigned
hype lawrence mass uh bt cipher with
french montana lawrence mass so that was
my thing was like put lawrence on the
map and uh differentiate us from boston
but still rep boston because boston is
the capital of course you know um with
this album who like you say you started
this project
did he start it we we kind of started it
together but the thing is he had a few
sessions with static on his own and then
i had a few sessions with static and
then we just started kind of messing
everything together fire i think i think
um
maybe the the pete rock song we did
which was one of the earlier ones we did
where it was like
the you know the first one we did was
probably one on give thanks right it was
us together but then i think the pete
rock might have been like second or
third after that and when we you know
we're on a pete rock beat that's huge
for me oh my god yeah for huge for
anybody anybody but anyway so both of us
you know we're just
talking about that like man we can't
believe we're on a p rock beat together
like that's dope and that that really
kind of brought us and the way we kind
of came on there to bring both of our
styles together you know what i'm saying
it was like
that was kind of like one of the main
dominoes that knocked the rest down and
then thailand was next yeah thailand was
next where it was like yeah
i made that and that's that's the one
with bun on it so
after that that's when he was like yo
you got something else you got something
that's when it was like
we had three and it's like bro you got
three yeah you might as well do a whole
project at that point yeah why not it's
like you know how some actors will be
like okay i want to go do a movie with
quentin tarantino i'll do it for free
right i just want to do it for free
that's how i was doing this type of
stuff right facts with the uh well i
don't mean money wise because that's
never an issue or topic but it's the
just the the opportunity to do this type
of music with people that you admire
respect
inspire you people that are iconic and
legendary it was like man we couldn't
wait to get in the studio on any beat
did any the static or the center so pete
rock or yeah tyler man we could not wait
and every every time we do something it
was
exactly that it was like working with
denzel or working with whoever you know
what i'm saying this is one of the
easiest projects i've done like paul's
the easiest guy to work with like so
easy i've had people who are not even
close to his status of an artist act
like a diva with me and i mean that [ __ ]
happens a lot it happens and that's just
you get the d-list artists that that act
crazy people are just if they act like
that when they get a little bit of clout
they've always been weenies right
yeah that's a funny word i ain't heard
that word
[ __ ] weenies man
um
for you like you've had so many
different eras of your career i feel
like um
you know obviously the way things kicked
off and then you started to uh
kind of hang with travis a lot and and
um
expensive taste and you know you you
collect you've collaborated with so many
artists
over your career man like what has kind
of been like outside of this project
like
your other favorite collab project
you've been a part of oh definitely the
ones with my heroes you know i got one
with slim thug that i love it's you know
very under the radar uh i got one with
little kiki that uh oh my god you can
put that in my grave um
you know put that in my casket when i
die i got one with rich de facto that we
haven't released yet i got one with the
jackal rest in peace dude all right yeah
we haven't we did that in like 2008 or
something 2009 and we just never
released it uh one day it'll come out um
but that one's amazing too a few uh
collab projects i got with you know
different producers i got a collab
project with day one
um we haven't released yet uh so i got a
lot of the unreleased but you know i
think the
terms of most favorite is probably
definitely a little kiki
and uh the rister factor one that hasn't
come out yet um but i'm looking forward
to it man me and dj fresh thinking about
doing one together we talking about it
uh so it's a it's a few i like doing
even when i was making albums i would
like to have like a
vibe or feel to it to where okay i got a
main producer we got a main producer who
produced
you know eight or however many tracks
right and then a few other producers i
[ __ ] with to do the rest right but at
least there's gonna be a core sound
you know saying whereas one main
producer doing so even now i've been
doing that like a little further like
i'll be exploring that a little bit more
where i do the whole project with just
one producer where it's a whole vibe and
you know it take a little while to get
to where you want to go as you work
together with the producer right they
can you know because they might have
their ideas you got their idea your
ideas and you just you know mesh them
together but you know when when you get
to go in with just to me that brings
back the the you know the when i fell in
love with hip-hop that's how i was it
was artists with one or two producers
doing the whole album not yeah
gumbo of a bunch of different random
singles
yeah right we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our sponsors
at blue chew the good thing about blue
chew not only does it make that dick
[ __ ]
you know what i mean
get that thing swinging like it never
swaying before
but what i love about blue chew is
it's all online man you know usually
when you want to go and get some of that
uh you know some of that good good some
of that blue juice maybe some viagra
first of all it's got the same exact
active ingredients as viagra and as
cialis but you don't have to go into the
doctor's office to get it all right all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com you
have an online consultation and then
they discreetly
send it to you and it's also a discreet
villain you know what i'm saying
it's crazy let me tell you something
maybe you got a first date you want to
make sure you blow them back out that
thing you know what i'm saying
pop that blue chew it's a chewable form
some people don't like swallowing pills
ladies are going to love to swallow you
though once you're on that blue chew
i'll tell you that much bud for sure so
what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg and you're
going to get a month supply of bluetooth
for free all right you're going to thank
me later for this yo can you give me the
uh
story about drive slow man drive slow
what's one of my favorite kanye songs
ever lay registration is my favorite
album yeah man that's a fire
playing pat um shout out to playing
pacquiao playing pat what up that's
what's up yeah he uh he he hit me up um
was like hey i know you uh you met kanye
you said y'all were cool i had i met him
at a uh at an interview we were all
doing like a big interview one time and
i talked to him about making him some
grills
and then from there that's what kind of
led to you know playing past saying hey
i know you met kanye you know why don't
we try to do a song together of course
i'm like yeah of course [ __ ] and he said
yeah i asked yeah he said he down with
it but you know he might not use your
verse you know he might not use the song
at all he might take you off donna you
know what i'm saying that's that's
basically what he was telling me yeah
you might get on there he might not like
it so if you do don't be mad but it's
opportunity and i'm like [ __ ] you ain't
got to tell me i know what i was even
back then before he was just kanye the
producer right you know people didn't
really respect his bars but at that time
i did i loved his bars i didn't like his
beats i thought his bars was
way doper than his beats at the time
because that particular style when he
was sampling a lot of the samples i went
into because right a lot of them so
samples didn't have the b the base right
right or they would have it but it would
come in and out so that they could
highlight the samples you know it just
is what it is i have my particular style
i like but it's bars i love
and i hear him talking about that how
people didn't want him to rap they only
wanted to make beats and i'm like what
y'all crazy this man was spinning but
you know when i had
even from then i knew the opportunity
was there amazing opportunity uh to get
on a song with kanye west and i didn't
think he was going to use it uh when in
there actually the verse i i did for
actually was the original verse i wrote
for sitting sideways when i did send
sideways at first it was
the first time i had ever did a song
with big pokey and lokiki was on it too
and it was the first time i had ever did
a song with lil kiki
but the record label atlantic said hey
big pokey is not signed to anybody he's
an independent artist little kiki's not
signing anybody he's an independent
artist
you being me all the artists who signed
the atlantic part of artists we trying
to push
albums the ones we trying to sell i know
these your homeboys but you can't put
them both on you put one of them on
there and i'm trying to explain like man
look they're not just my homeboys these
are legends the originators of the sound
you know these are the originators of
the houston culture right like it's
bigger than just somebody i like and
listen to but they didn't really see it
or get it and i don't know maybe they
were right they uh you know we ended up
having to take somebody out we took a
little kiki off big pokey was on the
sample so i felt like well if he was on
the hook so i felt like well if we gonna
sample him for the hook we should give
him a verse on there as well you know
and at the end of the day even though it
was my song i felt like it's really big
pokey song because it's his
his sample for the hook you know
uh but
i i originally had a verse that i wrote
because this is how i used to write i
used to get like brain fog so if i'm
anywhere and i hear music on i can't
think because the music is just it's
just
distracting me or you know i'm talking
to you i'm looking at the plaques on the
wall instead of focusing on my verse so
i would get a beat get the tempo maybe
come up with an opening bar
and then go into the bathroom where it's
quite going to my car outside where it's
completely silent and just right in
silence so all i can focus on is just my
verse so sometimes i do that come back
and lay it and the tempo will be a
little off because i'm
right in your car yeah yeah yeah yeah
not to the beat yeah i go back in there
and there's a little also that's kind of
how it was i i went in there i spit the
verse my original verse which ended up
being the drive slow verse and my boy t
ferris was like it was me little kiki
and big pokey and right at the very
beginning of the song say is is big
pokey
little kiki and wild baby but they had
to mute out the little kiki so it's big
pokey
and wild baby
when you hear you like okay damn they
didn't mute it out but anyway t very say
look
man the verse hard nah i ain't saying
it's whack but it don't go with the beat
it just don't flow with the beat i rea i
really think you should write a new
verse because you already got to write a
new one anyway right to replace little
kiki's verse so i really think you
should write two new verses that go to
this song just try it and i was like man
you crazy this verse hard you crazy t
paris was like my coach he was like the
main person that believed in me he saw
the vision for it when i couldn't see it
when i thought i was over and done you
know in 2002 when i thought i was over
and done that was the end of my that's
what everybody in houston was telling me
to by the way i wouldn't [ __ ] without a
millionaire chiefer come say man look i
believe in your best day is in front of
you not behind you man i don't think
you you uh better would commit of course
you all doped together but i think you
dope being yourself he really kind of
gave me that encouragement and believed
in me and when i didn't when i thought
it was over so okay he's telling me
man okay this this versus hard but redo
it i'm like man you crazy then it kind
of snapped in my mind i could see the
disappointment in his face and he's like
all right if you don't if you don't
wanna you don't even wanna try it it's
cool you the artist it's your word
whatever you say i'm gonna go with it
but i just think you should try it's
cool and i said man you know what i'm
letting my i let my coach down man yeah
phil jackson called up a play i'm not
going to beat scotty pippen on the bench
now i ain't going in the game right you
ain't giving me the ball i'm going to
get now man my coach calling to play he
knows something or he sees something or
he's planning something that i don't
comprehend yet don't matter i'm not the
coach he's the coach yeah i gotta let
him do his job with coach and at the
very least i could try it and if it's
whack we ain't gotta use it so i said
okay i'm gonna try the two new verses
boom they're sent sideways but i had
that original verse in my pocket like
okay i'm i know i'm saying some [ __ ] on
here i'm gonna save this for
if you know jay-z want me on the verse
or you know what i'm saying or somebody
want me on something and i've been out
all night and i ain't got time and we in
the studio like man and it's a big major
opportunity i'll kind of use it for that
so when playing pat hit me and say i got
something i think and i say man first
thing i thought was man what that verse
said
when found it to write them on paper
yeah fine and i used to say them because
we'll write out we'll write our verses
and sometimes you know the hard drive
will crash or something so if you don't
have it saved somewhere oh well it's
over rest in peace to your verse yeah so
i learned a lesson man i got to save
the written verses so somewhere i got
the actual written verse somewhere uh
you know i said lft yeah
it's coming man it's coming
for sure oh yeah but when it it worked
it i laid it playing past say man look i
did it in my studio sent it to him
playing past say look kinda like it but
he wants you to come out here to l.a and
lay it because he got a few things he
wants you to do maybe something for the
hook maybe this he's got a lot of ideas
man bet but at the whole time i'm
thinking at the end of the day my verse
is not gonna be on there something is
gonna happen to prevent my verse from
being either he's not gonna like it i'm
gonna be whack or it don't match or
something somebody the label not gonna
like it somebody you know something i
just had it i'm sitting my mind i'm
gonna do whatever i got to do
ain't no way this verse going on there
man they taking me off with dondo man i
knew that man
but even when we landed out there man
remember we landed in l.a
we we're coming down the escalator lax
going to the baggage claim and as soon
as we get to the bottom of the escalator
two detectives one come to my boy goo
one come to me
say yeah man they start talking to us
i'm like man we getting punk because
mike jones had just got punked so when
you get pumped you punk somebody else so
i was like man they coming they try to
try to i think travis barker got punk
too so i'm like man i got it from
multiple angles i'm like man i i hope
i'm they about to try to punk me man i
ain't gonna punk me so i was ready man i
come down there detectives you know they
hey where are coming from this and that
i'm talking crazy to them cause i'm
thinking they're actors you know you're
like i'm about to go i don't talk crazy
to police because i know what they
capable of
[ __ ] and it's the la you share support
whatever that man come on man they
easily could have come with us and then
[ __ ] it would have been a long night for
me but and i looked at my boy good he's
just looking at me like crazy like man
what you doing man you talking crazy i'm
just talking disrespectful you know just
going off on them and then the officer
that was on me the other he was getting
upset and the other officer was like
what was going on man come on let's just
go and then they just went to somebody
else they just wanted to check out bags
i don't know i'm just like
what y'all ma'am ain't got [ __ ] going on
you know [ __ ] gotta get to a kanye
session yeah so i'm thinking okay i knew
he was getting pumped ain't no kanye
session you know whatever then they
leave and i'm like wait where aston
could you head we ain't getting [ __ ]
and goo like now dummy we ain't getting
pumped with you he's about to get us
arrested yeah and could you really have
people out here [ __ ] almost getting
[ __ ] up in these streets
hey that ain't it then we went to the
hotel okay i dropped gu off goose stay
the hotel and i went to the studio
session i'm in a car service going to
the studio session we pull up to the ho
to the studio
the driver don't exactly know where the
studio is at because it's not you know a
big giant sign outside to say studio
here right so he pulls up we're in the
left-hand lane the far left-hand lane
the studio is on the right
we're at a stoplight
it's red he say i don't know oh there it
is right there and he just break
everybody off his red light he just
turned he went far left hand lane he
turned right over three or four lanes of
traffic and turned right onto the street
it just so happened it was a cop right
there he couldn't see he was getting
blocked so we get pulled over i'm like
[ __ ] they couldn't give me any part one
at the airport so now they punking me
i'm like i knew it's too good to be true
doing something kanye man you know he
getting it he getting a ticket all this
kind of stuff i'm asking the cop man can
i can i leave can i go and he's like
yeah i ain't giving you no ticket i'm
like [ __ ] i'm out i go do my verse i'm
like [ __ ] whereas the kitchen [ __ ] it
ain't so even even up until it came out
it wasn't until dj drama called me and
he said hey you want kaye album i was
like i don't know it ain't come out yet
they might have took me off down there
right so yeah so [ __ ] like now you on
here we i'm at the listening party now
come out tomorrow or next week whenever
he's like nice on hill you on here i'm
like damn no [ __ ] like man and it's fire
man shout out to playing paper how much
of the song was like did they just send
you the beat or was the song pretty much
done when he sent when i first
originally did it was just the beat it
was no hook no nothing it was just the
beat and he was like it was a concept
the concept is just drive slow but i
didn't know like where he went with his
verse it was like you know be cautioned
you know be cautious when you're living
your life don't live a fast life drive
slow in your life you know it was more
you know
conceptually like a different type of
well i went slab with it you know what
i'm saying well i was talking about
really driving slow in the car it was a
little bit a little bit different and
glc came at the end
uh you know killed it too yeah shout out
glc man the whole the whole thing put
together man was
it was uh definitely you know when i
heard it when it was finished you know
i'm saying it was definitely definitely
very different than when i first laid my
verse to it but you know that's
that just goes to the vision of kanye
man when he got a vision for some man
and he put it together man he's a genius
that's a big deal man it's a big deal
hey that's why i still ain't hey i know
just hey he can re-release that [ __ ]
right now without my verse and what am i
gonna [ __ ]
it ain't taking me off down the boat
wasn't there two versions of that record
it was like a live version right there
well it was that version and then it was
a another version with ti with t.i like
it was like a kind of like a remix was
the same thing it was the same song yeah
just was with t.i's verse added and nti
put it on his album so that was [ __ ]
even then when we did the song we did it
on
kanye's album but craig calvin who was
ceo or i don't know what his title
president is something whatever he's
still there now in atlantic yeah he was
like hey how are what you think why oh
why don't we put that on your album too
and people don't do that you know we do
that on the underground of course but
when it's a kanye west song man ain't no
way kanye letting you put his song on
your album so i'm like man
is he gonna do that for the label yes
man the label ain't no way the label
gonna clear right but jay-z was the
president of the depth jam let it go
shout out to hove shout out and then i
seen hover the mtv awards and he said
hey you know you owe me right i'm like
[ __ ] hey what you what i don't know
what you want i got it you need a girl
what
that's so crazy so that was originally
going to be on the original sitting
sideways the verse yeah the reverse
because the original since i was i only
had one verse and that was that was it
so
when you go back to i don't know maybe
we need to do you need to do a blend or
that verse with the sin sideways beat to
see how it would sound shout out to t
ferris who's doing this thing right now
with megan yeah man shanti fairies who
saw the vision who's because houston
legend man for real if he if he wouldn't
have told me hey man do something else
then you know
the dominoes wouldn't feel that way they
did a big shout out to fears that's fire
yeah it's funny because i remember when
i uh interviewed megan and he introduced
himself i was like t fair pull up yeah
yeah
your name shout out
so many times
he's famous without knowing who he is
that's [ __ ] uh what's going on with good
dad gang man we got the we got the shoe
coming yeah i'm really excited about the
sneaker uh so with the ewing shop
patrick ewing man yeah man so basically
you know every father's day we've been
doing like different drops last year we
did uh gangstar good dad gangstar with
the premiere where we put the gangstar
logo together with the good dad gang uh
we did the diamond collab the year
before
uh so this year you know we decided to
step it up we did uh 600 pairs
exclusive
patrick ewing good dad gang collab man
so i'm really excited for that drops uh
in may does patrick do we still own
ewing he does he he he owns part of it
uh but he coaches for the uh the hoyas
yeah so you know he i believe he has a
deal with nike so i think that's why you
probably don't see him wearing the shoe
as much but he definitely like you know
is involved with it and and his family
is and and they're a fan of of this
sneaker where can everyone support just
because for people yeah here's fly the
hats will fly
where it's good gang.com uh you can
follow us on instagram good.gang we've
been rocking for seven years now started
out as a hashtag
uh real grass grassroots movement and
just
had so much uh
support you know i'm saying i've had
jamie foxx call my phone and be like yo
i love the brand how can i help he put
it on his instagram
uh you know people like ludacris
charlemagne the god uh bun beach deluxe
we had a commercial last year with ice
tea and uh logic and uh
llc two chains you know so a lot of
people have co-signed the brand and uh
yeah it's only up from here man because
what we're doing is just promoting being
a good parent i mean you can't really
hate on that nobody can hate on that man
yeah so the sneaker drops uh in may
hopefully
uh everybody will get it in time so you
could wear it on father's day which is
june 19th june 19th big day for you guys
yeah every year every year just for me
as a dad you know because i didn't start
good that game to make money i started
it just because i love my kids no
i just think it's a dope dope thing to
like push man yeah but it's fire people
love it it's funny like every time i see
jada kiss he's like good dad gang y'all
good dad gang it's like it became uh
like a staple you know and people
tag it everywhere when they when they
chill with their kids and they got we
got 100 tattoos people tattooed all over
the world different countries i've seen
yeah yeah we got 100 tattoos now so it's
it's cool man i also wrote a book got a
book dropping later this year too good
game
so father [ __ ] so it's called 100 ways
to be a better dad and so basically what
i did was you know i went through a
bunch of stuff like i went to uh the
self-help section and uh borders and uh
i noticed that there was only five books
about fatherhood and there was like 200
about motherhood of course right so the
five books was like uh how what to
expect when you're gonna be a dad that
was one book another book was how to
help your wife
you know when you're expecting a baby
right but there was nothing that said
how do we help a man how do we help a
single father how do we help
a husband how do we help
somebody who's coming out of prison but
wants to be in their kids life how do
you how do you get back into your kid's
life how do you help uh somebody be a
parent when you were uh
you grew up in an abusive household
and you don't want to be like that with
your kids moving forward so i touched on
all those different topics
and this book is like a one-of-a-kind
book there's never been a book for
single dads uh nonetheless urban dance
right so i'm really excited about the
book and uh yeah that's coming later
this year too hey man damn y'all was
busy as hell man yeah we work man we've
been working on this side yo we got to
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our partners at odd socks
watch this i bet you i got out socks on
right [ __ ] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're going to save 20 off at
checkout they got so many crazy ass
socks we got twizzlers [ __ ] halloween
uh
i mean these are kind of satanic it just
says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like uh
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[ __ ]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon we keep going but what's
most important is odd socks is our
family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleghead podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you could also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [ __ ] right
now all right let's get into the uh
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're going to get back to it
right now are you still doing acting
stuff for uh i'm waiting to be
discovered
you been like some [ __ ] though yeah but
i ain't been discovered yet
i'm trying to be discovered man so hey
what's up hey holla at me i feel like
you've made like cameos it's like yeah a
couple cameos in there a couple little
small rolls i forget what i was watching
something and i was like out the [ __ ]
paw walls in this what's going on yeah
you got to kind of put yourself out
there you know that's one thing i i
never really did i never really like
went on a whole lot of auditions or this
or that i just kind of you know
dibble and dab or whatever come on
for sure yeah for sure for sure yeah
that's why i just kind of just would hey
whatever come my way every now and then
i got a friend doing a movie or this and
that and they throw me in there my boy
moe amber he um got a he's a comedian
from houston he got a tv show on i think
hulu and i think netflix matter of fact
about to come out he's a immigrant from
kuwait
and palestine his family came here and
he's got a hell of a story he tells it
in his stand-ups um or just of his mom
being such a huge hero for their family
and just what it was like for him as a
child growing up coming from there
coming to houston southwest side
the southwest side is a very cultural uh
man this southwest side of houston is
where uh it's a lot of immigrants in
that area so that's where there's like a
a chinatown korean town you know kind of
thing that's where there's a huge
nigerian population that's where there's
a big palestinian palestinian population
all of that so in that section you know
where he grew up he talks about how you
know
you people uh uh mistook him for being a
mexican so like the all the gang bangers
will be trying to bang on them because
they think he's in the gang and you know
this and that then when they find out
he's muslim this you know people oh you
know you know whatever
i'm liking my brother like
it just he talks about all that so the
show is based on his life i got like a
little small role in that that's fine
fire um how just as a you're a sports
guy
i you how do you feel about desean
leaving did you like the hall you got i
mean uh
you know
we let's talk about astros
[Laughter]
man let's talk about the celtics
we can talk about the suns if you all
really want to you know charles
barkley's behind you on the wall yeah
yeah we we definitely we uh we don't
know how i don't know how to feel you
know do you know any of the massage
therapists
i don't actually at least as far as i
know but i i do know some that he might
have he hit up that he never went to see
you know but just getting somewhere for
a massage is like well i don't know
because there's part i don't i want this
the the good person in me i hope he
didn't of course none of this so i want
him to i want to believe him but i also
you know i know the reality that you
know most women who get assaulted or any
of that they don't give their stories
not believe so it's like damn
how do you feel i've been falsely
accused of something though so i know
that feeling of somebody falsely
accusing you just because of spite you
know and it's like [ __ ] you know how do
you
how do you juggle that so as a texans
fan
now you got lovey smith and davis mills
yeah yeah and by the way i want to thank
you guys for trading us uh deandre
hopkins
i hope david johnson's working out for
you man man bro as texans okay it starts
off with when it takes his pass in the
draft on
uh vince young and reggie bush that's
and got david carr instead now even
though they say
you know i mean sorry ain't got mario
williams said even though they say mario
williams had the better career of the
three texans fans we wanted vince young
vince young won rookie of the year yeah
and we wanted if we couldn't get this
young
reggie bust for a [ __ ] show jeff jeff
fisher ruined vince young man yeah oh
yeah and after that they didn't give him
a chance after that after they black
bought him but even when they traded
deandre hawkins man we like first no
even before that when they let andre
johnson
uh you know future hall of famer go to
the indianapolis colts the fans are like
what are you doing this is the only
bright spot we have as the texans ever
ever yeah and he's potential hall of
famer y'all going to let him go to our
rival
the arizona texans we got j.j while we
got married
then i got deandre hopkins we like what
are y'all doing we got deshaun watson
and deandre hopkins and y'all going to
trade away
davis mills and who's catching over
there oh there's still the one dude
what's it what's the guy
yeah the guy's always [ __ ] injured in
fantasy we'll fall fuller
yeah
and then the rockets you know you got
jelly you got jalen green and christian
wood is good rockets we looking good man
although we lose no they're young but
they're losing again yeah as long as we
can get that cohesiveness going we're
going to be all right man because
celtics are killing it they're killing
it right now from the 11th seed to the
one seed yeah man celtics is on fire i
went to uh recently i went to kg got his
uh jersey retired i saw that yeah up in
the rafters he did not give a [ __ ] he
was letting all the curse work yo the
funniest [ __ ] is he comes out it's a
bunch of little kids all around right he
comes out he's like boston i know y'all
[ __ ] with me i know you [ __ ] with me
like this i'm looking around it's like
little kids with mom's [ __ ] it was fire
though man shout out to kg definitely a
legend and uh you know one that one that
helped win that that chip for us at 08
so you know shout out to the patriots so
oh man hey listen man tom left but you
know we still in the game man are you
yeah hey we did we did eye last year
we're in the playoffs you did all right
last year did i but what are you gonna
do this year um you know what to be
honest man because the dolphins got
[ __ ] tyreek hill and right i'm die
hard patriots fans
it's nice you got you got a lot of rings
to sleep on at night even if you guys
suck for the next 20 years who gives a
[ __ ] even the years when we was bad i go
to the games like i'm a die hard like
even even even the celtics when it was
like the antoine walker antoine those
those years bro we were horrible the
tickets were ten dollars ron mercier
we're still all up in the in the stands
all the way at the nosebleed i'm a die
hard you know what i'm saying i rock
with my teams i don't run away but i am
a tom brady fan so i'm ready to go he's
coming back one more year allegedly so
we'll see oh no not allegedly he's
coming back so you know i'm rooting for
tom as well
are you more of a brady fan than a
patriots fan at this point no i'm more
of a patriot fan but the thing is if we
don't make it i'm going for tom like my
dad got a jersey that's happening so
patriots have patriots patriots bucks in
the super bowl pages you're rooting for
the patriots pictures yeah but even like
even though tom brought the rings yeah
but it's my hood you can't go against
your hood all right but it's like 51-49
you know i respect that yeah that's an
honest answer because it will be because
i'm a tom brady fan you have to be yeah
but i'm not going to go against my squad
yo i saw like in in was it ted 2 where
the uh where ted breaks into tom brady's
house
i like that that's his [ __ ] i was like
this is the most boston ass [ __ ] i've
ever seen yeah yeah shout out to it
is it frustrating to watch tv and like
people try to do the boston accent they
[ __ ] well i think it offends people
like actually from the the city of
boston right me being from lawrence we
don't really have that you guys don't
have the cow cow [ __ ] the cow
slain you talk like that for sure like
you know me static uh rex like uh the
law town we kind of really we kind of
sound like we're from new york for some
reason that's true
yeah
i don't know why but
uh the boston they have a real thick
accent in like matapan dorchester
roxbury you know what i'm saying
i feel like a girl could be a 10 and i
hear a talk from boston and i'm like get
the [ __ ] out of here you sound terrible
that that that has turned me off from
women before like sweetheart you sound
like [ __ ]
yeah i don't know like friends wrestling
yeah something well i appreciate you all
pulling up the album is out yeah and you
guys have physical copies of the album
yeah we sold out of the vinyl already
man so you know the vinyl sold out we
got a couple cds left
uh you know the cd was inspired by one
of paul's uh other albums it was a
little bit uh out mind over matter
wasn't it so yeah we just freaked that
cover it's just a lot of paper shout out
to mike frost you guys got bitcoin on
here you guys got the bitcoin yeah yeah
yeah you know he just kind of took a
little bit everything paused into it
during the bitcoin point and then the
crypto a little bit man a little bit i
don't know nothing about it but i i i
learned to trust the experts yeah that's
what i'm doing okay just don't get that
rug pulled up from there under you like
everybody else yeah yeah that rug pull
[ __ ] is serious yeah you got to be aware
that coming after uh nba played yeah
darren fox from the kings said he want
to quit yeah i don't want to do this if
you want to focus on basketball yeah no
[ __ ] yeah you just said 180 million
dollar deal yeah you're rich already
relax
we appreciate you all pulling up man go
support the album where can they buy the
actual vinyl and all that uh so the
vinyl sold out but where can they buy
the cds yeah the cd oh you know the link
is in my bio on instagram at
terminologyst and uh at paul wallbaby so
yeah just hit the link up and you got
damn grease on here yeah shout out to
damn greece that's my dog dang man
listen go get this [ __ ] album all
right appreciate y'all pulling up